wirken können wer konnte punkten sieben
kandidaten und kandidatinnen waren für
den einen stuhl im kanzleramt
beziehungsweise für viele sessel im
plenarsaal und gespannt sein durfte man
ja auf den gemeinsamen auftritt der
unions kontrahenten söder und laschet
und gab es hinweise auf koalitions
vorlieben schlussrunde der
spitzenkandidaten wer hat überzeugt
unser thema jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend hier aus berlin
reden wir über diese diskussion aber
vielleicht auch etwas allgemeiner über
diesen wahlkampf so kurz vor der
wirklichen entscheidung kristina dunz
ist bei uns stellvertretende leiterin
des hauptstadtbüros von rn der
redaktions netzwerk deutschland und seit
dem jahr 2000 berichten sie ja schon
über bundespolitik und vor allen dingen
auch viel über cdu und das kanzleramt
und ich freue mich dass moritz kirchner
hier ist der ist psychologe verhaltens
und kommunikationstrainer aber auch
politikwissenschaftler herzlich
willkommen und zugeschaltet sind uns
antje hermenau sie ist politikberaterin
aus sachsen früher war sie mal für die
grünen im bundestag und auch im
sächsischen landtag hat auch mal für die
freien wähler kandidiert aber inzwischen
hat sie sich aus der politik
zurückgezogen schönen guten abend nach
drei arten und ich begrüße alexander
kissler er ist politischer korrespondent
in berlin für die neue zürcher zeitung
guten abend herr kißler und jetzt herr
kirchner so rum ist es herr kirchner wir
haben jetzt sieben personen da gesehen
zwei moderatoren also es war wirklich
die große runde 90 minuten lang wer war
für sie jetzt der überzeugendste wenn
wir fragen hatte überzeugungskraft
stellen dann brauchen wir erstmal im
metrik woran wir das fest machen und bei
unserem debattieren haben es immer
klassischen fünf kriterien gemacht
auftreten sprachkraft sachverstand
urteilskraft kontaktfähigkeit und wenn
ich mir diese fünf kriterien angucke und
denn wirklich die 90 minuten resümieren
lasse dann wird tatsächlich sein dass
janine wissler ganz knapp vorne war weil
sie ihre punkte ziemlich gut gesetzt hat
einen sehr sehr viel sandten stil
gefahren hat in der zentralen frage die
der linken vorgeworfen wird der
enteignungen das ding zurück gespielt
hat jan armin laschet in der frage von
nrw und hat gleichzeitig aber auch
gesagt wofür sie steht das heißt sie hat
noch lebten nach innen und nach außen
gewölbt und auf einem geteilten zweiten
platz um die frau noch 200 fand herrn
lindner bis auf den anfang kubicki hatte
die frage einfach nicht beantwortet
hinten raus ist aber gekommen und ich
möchte ihnen an der stelle auch sagen
frau backwaren ihren kernthemen sehr
überzeugend wir haben sie aber mit einem
doppelten söder paradox zu tun ich weiß
soll mittel- oder paradox besteht in
folgendem der mann hätte eigentlich da
sein sollen war aber unglaublich präsent
weil sonst hat die csu niemand sonst
gestellt und wahrscheinlich hat sich die
cdu das gedacht oder die union als eine
verstärkung aber es ist sehr deutlich
geworden dass die union so hätten ebenso
und nicht laschet weil der es ehrlich
gesagt ganz schön ab also man hat sie
jetzt gemerkt noch mal dass ich der
bessere kandidat gewesen wie es war in
den letzten 90 sehr deutlich ok und es
eigentlich ist ja jetzt der
csu-spitzenkandidat alexander dobrindt
richtig von daher ist es nicht so ganz
nachvollziehbar warum er da war okay
trotzdem fanden sie am überzeugendsten
ich fand sehr interessant wie frau
wissler es geschafft hat doch rot rot
grün in die debatte für einen richtigen
politik wechselt zu werfen herr scholz
hatte ja noch mal sehr klar die punkte
aufgezählt die für ihn nicht gehen mit
den linken also punkt nato
verfassungsschutz und sie hat eigentlich
gesagt na ja wenn wir das wir haben ganz
viele übereinstimmungen linke und spd
und da muss man einfach miteinander
reden frau wissler ist die bei den
linken die sehr sehr skeptisch auf
regierungsbeteiligung ihrer partei
blickt und man hatte in der partei immer
so die sorge dass sie vielleicht diese
chance jetzt dass die linke in die
regierung kommen könnte verpassen wird
weil sie zu kritisch ist und das hat sie
heute abend einfach mal beiseite
geschoben und das fand ich sehr
interessant dass tatsächlich ein blog
auf dieser seite frau baerbock von den
grünen herr scholz für die spd und frau
wissler für die linken tatsächlich sich
so in dieser sendung auch ein bisschen
arrangierte und ernährte es glaubt
präsentiert das möchte ich
unterschreiben ja frau hermenau aus
ihrer sicht wen fanden sie da besonders
überzeugend heute abend naja nachdem
herr lindner aufgetaut ist wurde ja in
der sache sehr konkret er hat allgemeine
ideen aufgenommen und auch betont dass
man da ja vielleicht auch zu den konsens
kommen können der wird nur einen ganz
anderen weg vorschlagen um das ziel zu
erreichen
und das wirkte sachkundig das muss man
mal zur kenntnis nehmen ich fand das
spiel zwischen söder und laschet jetzt
nicht nur vergiftet sondern es hat
natürlich auch ein bisschen was von dem
ein etwas aggressiver angreifenden und
von dem anderen der mit dem florett von
hinten kommt und der armin laschet hat
23 punkte gemacht zb wir müssen bauen
ein einfacher satz mit drei wörtern
klarer hauptsatz und klar formuliert und
da mussten sich die anderen erstmal dran
rum abklappern und beißen also das dann
wird er vielleicht unterschätzt und die
frage ist jetzt wer ist der beste
wahlkämpfer ich glaube da hat der sollte
wirklich die nase vorn die frage die
leute aber an wird in der wahlkabine ist
die frage wer wird der bessere kanzler
aber wer das ganze könnte das ja dem zu
sagen den leuten sehen konnten naja der
laschet kann aber auch mal jemanden
durchlaufen lassen und hält das aus und
so weiter und ist in der lage die alle
wieder einzusammeln den eindruck hat er
schon ein bisschen gelassen ich fand es
sehr anstrengend für frau weil die
mehrmals unterbrochen worden ist und
dann immer versucht hat die situation
wieder unter kontrolle zu bringen bei
beiden moderatoren das war vielleicht
unnötige wurde im laufe der diskussion
dann auch bessern können wir gleich noch
mal drüber reden bleiben wir mal bei den
der herr kessler wien fanden sie jetzt
am überzeugen sie hier war ja ganz klar
die das votum für frau wissler wie sehen
sie das dann würde ich mich nicht ganz
ganz anschließt jetzt schon ein bisschen
gefeiert von tisch bei der frage und
alpen oder nicht und dass ich dann
diesen satz ausgerechnet nochmal
wiederholt hat bauen bauen bauen ist
nicht die lösung ja was denn bitte schön
schott sonst also ich finde alle haben
mittlerweile anrollen profil entwickelt
anhand dessen man sie erkennen kann die
stärke von scholz ist die
perfektionierte plätze und diese besser
lässt eben auch kritikpunkte abfallen er
hat natürlich sich glücklich schätzen
können dass er heute wieder auf fahrt
noch auf den kampf comex skandal
angesprochen worden ist überraschend war
für mich lindner der wirklich als
staatsmann aufgetreten ist der sowohl
herrn söder einmal als die hofer
entlarvt was den puck mit der
schuldenbremse angeht wo eben in der tat
schon mal zwei mal vorgeschlagen hat das
doch bitte nicht zu eng zu sehen und hat
zwei mal eben auch gezeigt eine
inhaltliche leere bei frau seidel in so
verfällt ich schon sagen dass herr
lindner an der rolle des staatsmannes
den besten auftritt gemacht hat und in
der rolle des des blassen mannes den man
aber nichts anhaben können aufgrund
seiner presse hat mittlerweile herr
scholz ein erstaunliches rollenprofil
entwurf
perfektionierte bläst er bleibt man
vielleicht mal gerade bei den dreien die
sich auch offiziell kanzler kandidaten
und kandidatinnen nenne nebenfrau
baerbock herr laschet und herr scholz im
vergleich zu dem trial frau dems hatten
sie hatten sie das gefühl die sind da
jetzt stärker oder
wirken die sich wirken die bedrängt
durch die anderen ich glaube dass herr
laschet bedrängt war durch herrn söder
das hat ihn ein bisschen gebremst fand
ich er hat sich auch einmal so ein
bisschen lächeln gezeigt als es eben die
replik von herrn lindner auf herrn söder
gab da hat er sich glaube ich so im
inneren so ein bisschen gefreut dass
auch er selber mal entlarvt wurde und
ich finde dass das eine sehr sehr
schwierige situation war weil herr söder
ein bisschen so wie der aufpasser da saß
dass das jetzt auch gut geht ich glaube
dass sich die csu auch entsprechend
deswegen in dieser runde so eingesetzt
eingebracht wie auch immer hat dass herr
söder persönlich da auftritt und er was
er ja sehr sehr gut kann und da
unterscheidet er sich eben von herrn
laschet sehr stark in kurzen klaren
sätzen die dinge auf einen punkt zu
bringen werden herr laschet erstmal
anfangen muss irgendwie zu erzählen und
dann ja auch häufig schon
abgewürgt wurde sozusagen dass er da zum
ende kommen soll das war hat ihn glaube
ich gebremst wir haben ihn in den tri
allen angriffslustiger erlebte so dass
er auch direkt auf herrn scholz vor
allem losgegangen ist und ich glaube das
war für die union nicht die beste idee
jetzt die beiden zeitgleich dahin zu
bringen weil man sich ja auch fragt wer
ist jetzt der kanzlerkandidat eigentlich
hätte das ja für beide auch
die csu will noch nicht die cdu und wir
können wiederum die nicht in bayern
leben nicht die csu will das ist es
richtig dass man beide dahin setzt es
ist grundsätzlicher dann hätte wie haben
sie gerade angesprochen spitzenkandidat
ist alexander dobrindt und das wäre ja
sage ich mache jetzt auch gar nicht so
verwerflich gewesen ich glaube dass es
herrn laschet schon sehr gedrückt hat er
sah auch fand ich nicht sehr
glücklich befreit aus ja sie sind die
sitzordnung ist frei auch erste runde
wird er alle gesetzt haben alle haben
einen stuhl gesetzt hingesetzt es war
eine anordnung wie in der französischen
nationalversammlung ein rechter blog ein
linker blog herr laschet hat auch mehr
mal gesagt die drei linken hat also
deine grünen zu den linken adressiert
und einsatz noch vielleicht zu wirkung
ich war
wenn ich die schwierige aufgabe gehabt
hätte mit herrn laschet ein stück zu
inszenieren
man hätte ich ihnen die grundregel
gesagt bewusst seine sätze immer
adressieren und bei händler schweben die
sätze oft in raum auch wenn sie gut sind
auch wenn er inhaltlich punkte macht
seit heute auch gemacht aber er versteht
ist nicht die sätze zu adressieren und
das ist die tragik dieses man muss das
vermutlich sagen scheitern denn
wahlkämpfers laschet er kann seine
botschaft nicht interessieren sind sie
also nicht ist kann ja so etwas sehr gut
herr söder hat immer eine süffisante art
jemanden zu provozieren mit einem
scheinbar harmlosen satz und dann knipst
oder bei jemand mit dem druck auf den
roten knopf hoch unsere reagiert sich ab
und silber grinst sich eins also es ist
schon eine kunst sag ich mal bekommen
die katze und damit auch etwas klarer
wahrscheinlich mit den kürzeren setzen
gerade dieses erste thema ccs bürger
dieser mord in idar oberstein
angesprochene kirchner das war so die
erste runde da war hatte söder dass das
letzte wort wenn fanden sie da gut also
vielleicht erst mal ganz kurz wir haben
bei armin laschet aber auch bei markus
söder ganz am anfang gesehen die mimik
ja die war total angespannt und armin
laschet weiß er auch herr wie viel auf
dem spiel steht um das problem ist das
war jetzt wirklich allerletzte chance ja
und auch hier hat er nicht wirklich ein
wirkungstreffer erzählte teil ist was
sie gesagt haben also dass das dort
diese sätze auch manchmal so schwebt nur
der punkt ist erst am ende mal wieder in
etwas gekommen was ihn schon oft
wirklich punkte gekostet hat erst
teilweise panisch geworden auch gegen
die moderation also dort hat man das
auch gesehen auch diesen druck und da
war da einfach vom stil hat deutlich
souveräner eines freiherrn anteilig
allerdings nicht das will ich klar dazu
sagen wir haben es erlebt dass alle mit
der moderation zu tun hatten und was ich
beobachtet habe ich möchte an der
schnell klar sagen ist dass insbesondere
bei den frauen an zwar egal ob das frau
weigel frau wissler oder frau berg war
von der moderation härter eingegangen
wurde als bei frau weil das heißt ich
will das nicht auf eine person
adressieren und das auch etwas was er
tatsächlich suboptimal in der moderation
fand ok also das ist die frage frau
sonst haben sie frau weigel empfunden
weil frau habe das ja eben angesprochen
habe ist das auch eine masche dann sich
dann sozusagen immer darauf zu bestehen
dass man wohl dann einfach weiter zu
reden und sich nicht an die regeln zu
halten ich habe bei ihrem tor im reakter
ich hab zwar weil ab und so das gefühl
dass sie genau das provoziert dann
abgewürgt zu werden um dann ihre kli
thiel wieder zu zeigen seht her hier
gerade öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk
geht nicht ordentlich mit uns um sie hat
ja bewusst themen dann gesetzt die mit
der frage nicht immer etwas zu tun
hatten und hat sich dann ja sehr
selbstbewusst dort
durchgesetzt oder auch eben süffisant
indem sie da
das zurückspielen wollte an die an die
moderatoren das glaube ich ist eine eine
masche ein trick einfach um das eigene
klientel zu bedienen und auf der anderen
seite fand ich aber dass sie doch gut
redezeit bekommen hat und ihre punkte ja
auch ausführen konnte und fand sie da
jetzt nicht besonders zurückgesetzt wer
darauf auch nur ganz kurz eingehen darf
jan werner müller hat in seinem buch
populismus geschrieben das ist ja immer
darum geht das volk gegen die eliten zu
setzen und dass dieses gefühls wir sind
diesen eliten moralisch überlegen dass
daraus jedweder populismus ob rechts
links liberal sie speist er sagt aber
auch populismus ist immer anti
establishment haltung und hier in dem
fall war natürlich der moderation das
establishment hat sie insgesamt vier mal
so einen kleinen satz so gesetzt oder
frau hassel soll diese dieses diesen
nicht anbieten mit always text tötete
warum haben die moderatoren den
angeboten dass solche situationen
entstehen das habe ich kritisiert und
ich gebe im nachhinein recht sie haben
recht auch frau berbalk und frau wissler
wurde öfter unterbrochen ich weiß auch
nicht was diese unsitte soll herr
kessler die haben sie es empfunden war
gab es eine klare abgrenzung von allen
zur afg
von anderen teilnehmer
selbstverständlich trotzdem gab es
natürlich auch inhaltliche debatten da
sogar zwischen 18 schon kurz erwähnen
zwischen frau weiter und windtner in der
wirtschaftspolitik muss natürlich steht
punkte gibt da hat sie ausdrücklich
gesagt wir sind für steuersenkungen die
fdp sagt das auch also da haben wir
einen punkt es wird natürlich die die
neuralgischen und hoch emotional
besetzten punkte für die afg also
migration et cetera wurden nicht berührt
insofern hat frau weiter hier durchaus
als wirtschafts fachfrau punkten können
und natürlich legt sie es auch darauf an
in situationen zu kommen in dem der
eindruck entsteht ich gegen die welt
weil die partei sein die gegen die welt
ist theo gegen den rest der welt hieß
früher mal einen film mit marius müller
westernhagen war auch drin mit frau
veitl muss immer drüber stehen all diese
gegen den rest der welt für euch und das
ist insofern hat sich darauf angelegt
was irgendwie eine zugewinngemeinschaft
zwischenmoderationen vorreiter
da war er noch ganz kurz ein haken da es
gab bei frau was hochinteressantes im
stil was sie ja anders hatte als alle
anderen kandidaten kandidaten sie war
nicht in ihrem tonfall sehr moderat sie
hat auch gerade für ihre weise ziemlich
langsam gesprochen weil sie im bundestag
für gewöhnlich auch durch das schnellere
reden hält und hat natürlich hinten raus
immer mal so diesen punkt gespielt ist
was sie sehr schöne analysiert haben
aber sie war in ihren botschaften nicht
minder radikal also sie hat einerseits
klar ihre steuersenkungspolitik
vertreten hat aber auch die
migrationsfrage in ein anderes thema mit
reingepackt und hat er erneut faktisch
den klimawandel geleugnet das heißt da
ist eine diskrepanz zwischen dem
moderaten stil und der radikalen
botschaft und das war da war sie die
einzige wo es diese in konkurrenz gab
okay aber die frauen mussten sich auch
ganz anderes durchsetzen
also ich kann da ja wisst ihr noch
nachempfinden wenn ein markus söder
markant sagt da brauchen wir eine klare
kante da brauchen wir eine klare linie
und damit eine sehr tiefe stimme da
müssen die frauen die auch in der runde
sind ja überlegen wie sie auftreten frau
wissler hat oft relativ schnell
gesprochen frau weiter betont langsam
das sage ich auch so bei frau berg war
es mal so mal so es kam ein bisschen
aufs thema an würde ich sagen aber das
ist schwierig sozusagen sich dann auch
durchzusetzen in so einer runde wo dann
männer sozusagen markieren das ist nicht
einfach und da ist die frage der im lag
auch eine entscheidende frage das stimmt
da haben sie recht jetzt haben wir
gesagt es gibt noch immer noch ganze
menge unentschlossener wählerinnen und
wähler freut uns glauben sie dass in
dieser schlussrunde dass das dazu
beigetragen hat dass leute jetzt wissen
okay da mache ich jetzt mein kreuz ich
habe wirklich zweifel ob die
tv-auftritte dass die tri elle und auch
diese runde
wirklich eine ganz dezidierte
entscheidungshilfe sind was ich mir
vorstellen kann ist dass man menschlich
versucht irgendwie die die diese
politiker zugreifen inhalte sind ja sage
ich mal nach lesbar oder manchmal
versteht man sie auch nicht oder
manchmal waren ja genau der sagt das was
ich möchte aber wie kommt jemand
menschlich rüber wie würde der sich in
krisen verhalten wie würde alles das was
man nicht in einen koalitionsvertrag
reinschreiben kann und was man in keinem
wahlprogramm nachlesen kann und was man
jetzt nicht weiß sondern wie geht
derjenige diejenige dann in
außergewöhnlichen situationen mit dem
land mit mir als bürgerin um und dafür
finde ich diese tv-auftritte wieder sehr
sehr spannend kann ich nervosität
erkennen kann ich souveränität erkennen
was liegt mir mehr also wenn herr söder
der frau berbalk sagt das wird jetzt
auch nicht besser wenn sie dazwischen
quatschen so in der erinnerung dann
würde ich sagen ob das ist jetzt nicht
so mein typ an kommunikation dann kann
man daraus eben einfach viel erkennen da
hatte er sich fand ich nicht gut im
griff mit dieser überheblichkeit und da
hat dass das kann eine menge
rüberbringen in diesen runden wie gehen
die miteinander um und so fühle ich mich
am
am besten ist menschlich am besten
aufgehoben aber es ist denn das erklärt
sich als psychologe und
verhaltenstrainer kann man das
trainieren wenn sie jetzt ein von denen
trainieren müssten was wäre das
wichtigste was wir gegen beibringen drin
das wichtigste was die leute hinbekommen
müssen ist dass sie authentisch sind
dass sie immer wiederkehrende
botschaften haben und dass sie bei
alledem auch tatsächlich schaffen aber
dann auch zb auf die fragen zu antworten
weil das muss man sagen war heute ein
problem und das möchte er sozusagen
durch die bank weg ja also das teilweise
wirklich eine minute anderthalb in dem
umweg gemacht hat bis auf die frage dann
tatsächlich geantwortet wurde ich glaube
das sind die drei wichtigsten ihren die
ich auch tatsächlich den leuten
vermittelt die ich selber coaching nicht
wichtig ist es nicht wichtiger meint die
botschaft loszuwerden als auch die frage
zu antworten hauptsache ich kriege meine
botschaft rüber da hat sich gedreht weil
diese technik die so genannte adler
strategie dh die sogenannte ich habe
eine frage oder die debatte kreise denn
so ein bisschen rum und meine punkte zu
machen sie es einfach zu häufig passiert
das ist mittlerweile verbrannt so genau
deswegen erwarten die leute auch dazu
recht ja dass die fragen oder punkte
angesprochen würde man auch ganz kurz
frau dunst auf die frage kurz ein genau
die frau hat das heute was gemacht ich
glaube schon und zwar aus folgendem
grund wir haben erlebt dass die mehrzahl
der leute gesagt hat keiner von den
dreien so das heißt dass die leute entry
allen gesagt haben also ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher wie heute ja durchaus
gesehen haben vielleicht ist die
wahlentscheidung doch eine andere wenn
die leute nicht wer jetzt nicht den
kanzler die kanzlerin wählen + wir
erleben ja und das hat colin crouch in
seinem buch postdemokratie ganz klar
gesagt personalisierung medialisierung
und inszenierung und die leute gehen
immer stärker machen die wahl immer
stärker an personen fest und genau die
haben sich ja heute präsentiert herr
kissler was glauben sie hat dass diese
runde heute kann dass menschen dazu also
dazu bringen dass jetzt wirklich besser
wissen wo sie ihr kreuz machen sollen
wollen
ich finde schon dass man menschen in so
einer verdichteten situation wenn sie
mit fragen die sie nicht kennen und auch
personen mit denen sie nicht oft ohne
beobachtung im raum sind reagieren
müssen dass man diese menschen gut
kennen lernt das finde ich schon frau
berg fand ich zum beispiel von anfang an
wesentlich angespannter als ein laster
laschet hat wie ein guter begonnen wurde
dann am ende erst wieder so hässlich und
unruhig mit seiner flehentlichen
klammert gehst du dir immer macht also
grauenhaftes muss man wirklich mal
abgewöhnen
durch die bank war frau bärbel er eher
angespannt wagt sich was sie immer macht
sehr viel aber sehr früh auch schon
versprochen hat mehrfach vom grund
gerecht stadt vom grundgesetz gesprochen
gleich um einfach gesagt man müsse
dieses mal sei diese probleme nicht an
genug gegangen et cetera pp sagte auch
dass er eine hohe erwartungshaltung in
horas stresslevel setzt rest der wille
vorhanden ist lastet war der einzige der
gesagt hat ich als bundeskanzler werde
das tun herr scholz will eine regierung
anführen und frau buckel haben dass die
grünen in führung sind da sind schon
ganz andere formulierungen das heißt man
hat ihr das das erst die leidenschaft
hingabe zur macht in sehr
unterschiedlicher dosierung gekommen und
am stärksten war eigentlich möchte ich
sagen der dank so macht bei bei frau
wissler wir unbedingt regieren und bei
herrn laschet er will obwohl eben die
mittel in der darstellung dafür fehlen
unbedingt kanzler werden eine
inhaltliche korrektur stimme allein und
so was sie gesagt haben außer einem
punkt nämlich holz hat in seinem
statement auch gesagt als kanzler möchte
und werde ich also bord hat er das ganze
auch wirklich in der sekunde die
regierung
die wahl haben sie mal zu testen wie die
leute zusammen passen ja miteinander was
vernünftiges land aus kaspern können
eigentlich die grundidee dieser heutigen
diskussionsrunde so hat jedenfalls den
eindruck und da fand ich auch schon ein
bisschen unglücklich dass man nach links
und rechts classic sortiert hatte aber
wahrscheinlich muss man von der
sitzordnung ja ja vielleicht muss das so
dann guckte also wie beim tischtennis
die eine seite macht das die andere
seite macht das als ob es da schon zwei
fertige regierungskonstellationen gäbe
wo man müsse zwischen den beiden
auswählen das fand ich der sache nicht
ganz angemessen oder
interessant gewesen was zu gucken wie es
anders erwirkt wir wollen einfach gelöst
hätte man ja keine ahnung aber das
immergrüne und überwasser klassiker und
da hat eben dass söder bisschen schöner
oder stärker besprochen als dann aber
das alles in eine richtung sozusagen
und es haben sich auch linda und auch
weiter so gar nicht immer richtig
absetzen können die waren ja oft in
einigen fragen richtig einer meinung bei
gravierenden fragen die wirtschaft- und
finanzpolitik zb kommentar sache
ähnliche sachen raus und die anderen
drei waren sicher auch oft einig und da
hat ja auch vor hassel mal sehr gezielt
zu recht vorberg nachgefragt wer sehen
sie jetzt für die enteignung oder nicht
bei den wohnungen sagen es ist doch
endlich mal also frau berbalk ist viel
gekreist heute und wenig auf dem ast
gelandet das muss man einfach mal sagen
ja kurz einen haken darf also in der
frage in der tat da wurde eine ganz
schöne runde gedreht aber zum beispiel
in der frage tatsächlich der
außenpolitik findet dass davon ihre
punkte noch mal sehr klar gesetzt einmal
anfang in der ersten frage wollen drei
punkte in drei klaren politikfelder aber
frau hermenau wo ich in explizit
zustimmen diese sitzordnung ja in der
verhandlung psychologie wissen wir wenn
wir uns gegenüber sitzen wird ist ein
konfrontativer damit wurde hier auch
tatsächlich eine blockbildung auch
symbolisch gemacht weil wenn ich jemand
angreifen möchte ist das ein unterschied
wenn ich jetzt wirklich hier sitze und
jetzt hier so reingehen also sv dunst
das würde ich jetzt bei ihm wehtun aber
es wäre schon deutlich wahrscheinlicher
und da ist in der tat so eine vorprägung
passiert will vielleicht noch mal kurz
auf die quelle man hätte ja auch sagen
können man setzt herrn lindner zum
beispiel neben herrn scholz wäre ganz
andere botschaft gewesen eigentlich und
uns wie sehr ist dann dieses weil das
ist ein punkt den die union jetzt ganz
stark macht jetzt vor diesem
linksbündnis wahrend auch am schluss ja
haben sie das ja und der hat doch statt
das ja auch noch mal ganz klar gemacht
inwieweit ihr haben wir jetzt ein
lagerwahlkampf
ich finde dass herr lindner egal woher
gesessen hätte genau das getan hätte was
er gemacht hat nämlich sehr die
botschaft zu setzen wir wollen mit der
union ich persönlich möchte mit herrn
laschet er hat ja zum schluss musste
erst mal so ein bisschen umrechnen als
er gesagt hat klar wird sein dass am
sonntag auch die stärkste partei aus
dieser wahl von 70 prozent der
bevölkerung nicht gewollt sein wird
diese botschaft ist also ihr seid die
beiden großen volksparteien sind bei
werden beide schwach genug sein dass wir
selbst auch aus einer position von platz
zwei der union eine regierung bilden
können und das ist für mich sehr
deutlich gewesen das hat er übrigens ja
auch während des gesamten wahlkampfes
gemacht er ist sehr eng verbunden mit
armin laschet und das ist heute abend
noch mal sehr gut rübergekommen und da
glaube ich hätte die sitzordnung keine
rolle gespielt
er hätte die botschaft gesetzt ich
möchte am liebsten mit der union hat
ja genau und bei herrn laschet ohne dass
er sich da festgelegt hat ist das
dasselbe gewesen das ist ja sehr auch
sehr sehr interessant gewesen dass herr
söder gesagt hat platz eins für
regierungsauftrag und er lacht genau
diese frage nicht beantwortet hat das
ein großer dissens innerhalb der union
dass herr laschet und sein umfeld es für
möglich halten würden von platz zwei
heraus eine jamaika koalition zu bilden
mit herrn laschet als kanzler und herr
söder sehr ichbezogen etwas weiter denkt
und sagt lieber gehe ich in die
opposition und lass die union voll
krachen und habe dafür dann mehr schub
für meine landtagswahl in bayern 2023
von uns schön analysieren oder was den
fehler glaube ich dass man selber dort
dazu gestellt hat aus unionssicht also
wenn man gerade immer diese karte spielt
es in einer geschwistern partei wir
werden nur gemeinsam siegen können ich
unterstütze dich voll und ganz so heißt
es zumindest rhetorisch wenn der
markusdom und auch machen wenn er markus
blume den mund aufmacht kommt nicht und
sagt also es hat heute ich wirklich noch
mal diese differenz dieser beiden
schwesterparteien gesehen wurde ein
fataler weise auch noch der vertreter
kleineren schwester zeit deutlich größer
ist ungefähr 20 cm
also hat die union die eine union die
gemeinsam siegen will und jetzt nicht
mal zu scharf zu sagen ich lasse heute
dem den vortritt der kanzler werden will
madrid dann auch für uns als
schwesterpartei mit an und der sieg für
uns und er spricht mit uns mit dass
bericht leider gegen oder leider aus
sicht der union spricht gegen die union
und wenn man wirklich diesen schmilzen
den vorsprung der spd attackieren wollte
hätte man dieses attacke dieser attacke
heute wirklich entlastet und damit auch
die bühne überlassen müssen aber da gab
es noch mal so ein paar spiele heißen
frau merkel auf dem parteitag der csu
war vor ein paar jahren und der herr
seehofer warb damals glaube ich noch
ministerpräsident und da hat sie da
neben dem mikrofon stehen drei vier
stunden drei flächen stehen in der trift
und einfach länger glauben und 15
minuten
es war richtig schlimm bei den hintern
versohlt und hat sie da warten lassen
und sie mussten sich das also alles
anhören und das alles das ist irgendwie
so ein komischer sadomaso ritus zwischen
csu und cdu habe ich den eindruck hier
aber die frage ist in goutieren die
wähler dass das weiß ich nicht das ist
ja die frage wie kommt das wie kommt das
an und was heißt das für sonntagabend 18
uhr noch mal ganz kurz in dieser
koalitionsfrage wenn man nur mal linda
betrachten da fand ich gab es drei
hochinteressante momente das erste war
er sei gefragt worden ist für sie die
beibehaltung der schuldenbremse
unbedingte bedingung für die koalition
hat gesagt ja und der punkt ist wenn spd
und cdu spd und grünen entschuldigung
ihre programmatik umsetzen wollen dann
wird das nicht ohne steuererhöhungen
gehen das heißt hier hat man einfach
programmatischen problem wenn er das
ausschließt zweitens er ist ja explizit
gefragt worden welche koalition er
präferiert und hat er dann gesagt also
mit der union beziehungsweise daneben
jamaica interessanterweise aber viel
interessanter war folgende passage frau
berger hat ihren punkt gemacht und er
sagte oh gott und
der verachtung da wiederum wetter doch
symbol politisch sehr deutlich wo er
tatsächlich persönlich in der
koalitionsfrage steht ok dazu sodass
wirkte zumindest die frage ist was heißt
dass sonntag 18 uhr bleibt es dann dabei
musik haben schon ein paar wahlen
mitgemacht und die
koalitionsverhandlungen zwei sind dann
haben auch alle sehr erstaunt
oder hat herr lindner zu stärken also
was heißt das wenn jetzt wenn wir sie
sehen die union ist irgendwie ist da
auch nicht einig in dem was sie was sie
eigentlich will mit platz eins oder zwei
wie sie umgeht herr lindner sagt zum
einen ob gott sagt aber andererseits zu
jamaika da gehören hier nun mal die
grünen mit dazu also was passiert denn
da oder sind sie schlauer nach dem abend
das ist das
wird sehr entscheidend darauf ankommen
wie nah oder wie weit voneinander
entfernt spd und union seien werden wenn
die ich halte es immer noch nicht für
ausgeschlossen dass die union diesen
rückstand bei der wahl noch mal sehr
stark verringern wird wenn die union
vorne liegt ist klar dann ist laschet
hat ja schon wieder alles richtig
gemacht und die union wird
zusammenrücken wenngleich er natürlich
das schlechteste historisch schlechteste
ergebnis der union
seit 1940 einfahren wird das ist sehr
klar weil die union nicht über 30
prozent kommen wird aber das
entscheidende wird sein wenn die union
so deutlich hinter der spd ist dass es
unanständig wäre zu sagen wir laden zu
sondierungsgesprächen über jamaika ein
weil das dann wäre man wirklich ein sehr
schlechter verlierer in dem moment
machen wir das in funktioneller ich
würde sagen wenn es also deutlich wäre
für mich wenn es bei den
umfrageergebnissen liebe die wir zuletzt
hatten 22 union 25 spd das ist für mich
deutlich wenn es bei 23 7 und 24 1 ist
dann würde ich sagen wird es wird auch
herr laschet zu sondierungsgesprächen
einladen wenn der abstand deutlich ist
wird die csu alles daran setzen dass
diese union erst mal in die luft fliegt
die man wird versuchen das herrliche
sehr schnell seinen parteivorsitz
verliert man wird sehr viel unruhe in
die bundestagsfraktion
hineinbringen und man wird deutlich
machen das hat herr söder während des
gesamten wahlkampfes gemacht hättet ihr
mich genommen dann hätten wir gewonnen
und ihr habt auch falsche pferd gesetzt
und ich wäre der bessere gewinnen der
sieger sich damit dann besser fühlt was
hätten sie damit gewonnen sie hätten
damit aussicht so weit ich das höre aus
der csu in bayern gewonnen sollte ist
ein rot rot grüne regierung meinetwegen
geben dann hat herr söder
bis zur landtagswahl in bayern in zwei
jahren die volle breitseite gegen die
bundesregierung als möglichkeit sich zu
profilieren
das ist häufig dann eine ein reflex dass
man sagt das will man genau nicht haben
deswegen muss bayern ganz stark werden
herr söder ist ein csu vorsitzender der
das haben wir sehr stark bei dem
parteitag in
nicht bei den taten doch bei dem
parteitag in nürnberg gesehen an einem
satz monat zu erklären herr söder hat
dem verkehrsminister andreas scheuer
dafür gedankt dass 40 prozent aller
milliarden in seinem bereich nachfeiern
geflossen sind
bayern first und so und so ticken die
sag ich mal und das würde er das
verfolgt er weiter und deswegen wird ist
darauf ankommt wie schlecht ist dass
unions ergebnis wenn sie auf den zweiten
platz kommt welche chancen hat laschet
sich noch hat laschet noch sich daraus
zu befreien indem er
zumindest zu sondierungsgesprächen
einladen könnte ich glaube das wird eng
beieinander liegen und ich glaube wir
werden eine situation erleben dass
sowohl der erste als auch der
zweitplatzierte auf jeden fall gespräche
führen kann über eine regierung mit zwei
anderen parteien also was ich
bekomme alle zeit die teile von uns ist
das wenn das so kommen wird ja das
tatsächliche abstand gibt dann gibt
schlachteplatte bei der union also dass
das ding ist an der stelle wirklich sehr
sehr klar was sie aber nach dem trainer
nicht teile ist ich hatte vorher auch
gesagt das drückt nochmal zusammenhang
nicht nach dem was wir gesehen haben
weil dadurch das ja auf den kunden
zusammen endlich die hätte genehmigung
hätte gedacht dass das noch ein bisschen
mehr zusammengerückt aber nach diesem
krieg oder nach diesem heutigen
siebenkampf glaube ich das nicht mehr
denn für die unionswähler rind
unionswähler wurde deutlich wer der
bessere kandidat ist nur in 15 von 16
ländern kann man den ja nicht wählen
weil erstmals versprechen ist dass man
laschet kriegt an dieser stelle und
wurde schon denken dass herr lindner
durchaus auch in konservative klientel
gepunktet hat also da könnte auch noch
was reingehen und ja durchaus er denkt
auch frau wisse auch noch mal ein paar
punkte für eingesammelt hat heißt glaube
dass heute das ganze nochmal dazu
geführt dass tatsächlich wirkt die
letzte chance verpasst wurde für die
union und in der konsequenz wir ab
montag eine situation der instabilität
erleben werden die sie sehr schön
skizziert habe auf der anderen seite
werden sie doch jetzt so gut war wenn
man sagt wenn man denkt man hat da habe
ich ja zwei dann sehe ich auch der
sieger spielt ja auch eine rolle dass
ich würde doch dann eigentlich dafür
sprechen dann die cdu dann doch zu
wählen richtig aber ich glaube es wenn
sich viel mehr leute warum habt ihr den
nicht aufgestellt jetzt kriegt ihr meine
stimme nicht und die gehen dann zwar im
zweifel zum beispiel des fdp herr
kessler die wollen halt sagen ja ich bin
mir da nicht ganz so sicher der baker
ist das scheue reh oder und launisch das
müssen wir alle man darf nicht vergessen
dass faktisch eigentlich söder noch
stärker mit dem rücken zur wand steht
als armin laschet die stoiber csu war
über 60 prozent die söder csu liegt
jetzt in umfragen bei unter 30 prozent
das heißt er wird momentan vielleicht
nicht mal nur mit mühe und not ein
zweierbündnis überhaupt zusammen kehren
können um sich an der macht zu halten in
bayern das ist die ultimative demütigung
ganz mieser umfragen das letzte
landtagsergebnis war schon sehr sehr
schwach er kann froh sein dass er dort
freien wähler gefunden hat die ihm also
aus regierungs fällt drauf heben
eigentlich mittelfristig betrachtet hat
söder viel viel mehr zu verlieren
und insofern glaube ich dass diese
gelassenheit wenn sie auch natürliche
professionelle gelassenheit ist die im
laschet versucht auszustrahlen heute
jetzt nicht dazu geführt hat dass die
union sich komplett aus dem feld
gekegelt hat man weiß der söder ist
wirklich keiner der kurz vor der
heiligsprechung zu sehen steht er hat
seinen ruf als andré hofmann nummer zwei
ich nochmal befestigt und insofern halte
ich das rennen nach wie vor oft genauso
ich denke auch das rennen ist offen man
hat ja im prinzip mit der sitzordnung
die lage abgebildet und die frage war
sozusagen welches lager ist stärker nun
gut auf der rechten seite saßen neben
vier leute und nicht 3 das ist der erste
punkt der zweite punkt ist man kann als
unions wähler auch denken man kriegt ja
schulter und doppelpack dann wird schon
passen manche die csu wählen müssen in
bayern hätten lieber cdu und manche die
cdu wählen müssen lieber csu das ist ja
auch ein altes geheimnis ob das trägt
weiß ich nicht weil es auch viele
menschen gibt die sagen also ich habe
der cdu so oft den hintern gerettet weil
sie als kleinstes übel so zu sagen da
steht aber ich mag nicht mehr ich hab so
satt die immer zu retten wenn die immer
so eine schwierige und gruselige politik
abliefern also das weiß ich nicht wie es
trägt emotional das kann man nicht
wirklich voraussehen und beurteilen auf
die frage mit den koalitionsbildungen
haben ja alle irgendwie elegant
umschifft lea bereich er selber ganz
hart wird und hier kommen die spannende
schlussphase frau prettner das ist
schlecht denn dagegen dass wenn beide so
ungefähr bei 24 prozent liegen die frau
kunstvollen auch gesagt haben dass dann
der olaf scholz wenn die spd vorne liegt
sagt du kommen wir machen wieder eine
große koalition hat auch schon macht den
kanzlern ok glauben sie dass ehrlich
warum nicht wenn alle anderen strenger
reisen wer weniger wenig mit den
arbeiten vom linken lager die linken und
die grünen wollen nicht mit denen
verbrechen lage gesprochen werden am
ende wohl das highlight eingangs bei der
mainzer im holz parteien jeweilige
volksparteien oder die grüne ist kennt
vielleicht die dritte neue volkspartei
aber normal class können sich das
vorstellen dass es doch noch mal zu
einer großen koalition kommt also meine
man kann ja politik nichts ausschließen
oder
in der tat haben wir sehr verworrene
konstellationen bei faktisch keine
dieser dreier koalition irgendwo vom
unproblematisch das teile ich in der
analyse was sie aber nicht teile ist
dass das passieren wird denn der punkt
ist das wäre doch die große koalition
unter umgekehrten vorzeichen
wo man sich rat also wenn ihr das jetzt
schon genau so gemacht und jetzt gemacht
haben die unzufriedenheit auch kreatives
das hat keine erzählung die ganze
geschichte da wird auch überhaupt nicht
deutlich dass da irgendwie im aufbruch
wechselt jetzt dass wir da nicht
mitmachen freut uns oder eine große
kollegin aya wenn das kanzleramt damit
gerettet würde er würde keine koalition
also glaube ich dass sie keine große
koalition unter olaf scholz machen
würden dass da wäre dann glaube ich auch
der frust im land doch sehr groß weil
sich wirklich nicht viel ändern würde
das
ist ein modell das wirklich nicht nach
aufbruch aussehen würde dass es sei denn
man weiß ja nicht was passiert wenn die
union wirklich unter der spd bleibt und
er lacht nicht mehr parteivorsitzender
bleiben würde und es käme dann eine
frische person konnte das nicht weil der
union naja alles was man so hört bei der
cdu
wir haben wir haben ja einen länger
währenden prozess immer um den
parteivorsitz erlebt wo immerhin sparen
der gesundheitsminister eine rolle
spielte jens spahn
würde ich mal sagen so sein lieblings
posten der unions fraktionschef zu
werden und in dem moment wo der
parteivorsitzende laschet nicht mehr da
wäre und es geht ja dann schon am
dienstag darum einen neuen
fraktionsvorsitzenden zu wählen da würde
es wirklich kann eine kampfkandidatur
geben und dann wird sich sehr schnell
zeigen was herr sparen aber er bringt
sich auch nicht so schnell zu ende nein
das sind beides typen beides männer die
sich das trauen herrn brinkhaus hat
damals herrn kauder aus dem amt gefegt
und herr spahn hatte zumindest die doch
die standfestigkeit damals gegen
annegret kramp karrenbauer und friedrich
merz anzutreten also noch dabei das wird
sehr sehr spannend am dienstag aber für
diese konstellation heller schritt wäre
nicht mehr parteivorsitzender und es
käme jemand neues dann wäre werden die
karten wieder neu gemischt also es muss
auf jeden fall aber etwas geben was nach
aufbruch und was nach vorne aussieht und
wer auch immer gesagt wir stehen für
neuen aufbruch aber sie sagt auch nicht
mit wem gehen das hat sich das hat sie
aus ihrer sicht sehr geschickt gemacht
und es gibt ja bei den grünen ein ganz
ganz wichtigen punkt warum für die
grünen jamaika attraktiver ist als die
ampel jedenfalls bei einem großen teil
oder bei dem realpolitischen teil der
grünen die grünen möchten gerne die das
mitte links spektrum der politik
anführen das war eigentlich mit ein ziel
in diesem wahlkampf das ist ihm
verhagelt worden durch kennen wir alle
jetzt ein paar fehler und dass die
umfragewerte runter gegangen sind
in einer von scholz geführten regierung
in einer ampel regierung oder rot rot
grün können sie das nicht erreichen weil
die spd davor ist in einer jamaika
regierung wäre der weg wieder frei und
deswegen hat frau baerbock heute abend
tunlichst vermieden in das linke lager
komplett verortet zu werden würde ich
ihn gekauft werden ganzen auch vor
gebaut sind der herr habe katar dem auch
vor gebaut in dem er vor zwei tagen in
den vier noch mal gesagt hat ja mit der
cdu könne er sich durchaus auch punkte
vorstellen stehen man sich einigen kann
und mit der fdp sei auch gespräche
möglich also ich glaube dass das eine
durchaus realistische überlegung ist die
kollegen eben teilt hat und das weite
teile der grünen aber wahrlich nicht
alle aber weite teile der grünen diese
realpolitische option vorziehen würden
allerdings ginge dies nicht ohne
besuchen ab gegenüber einer fraktion in
der natürlich dann auch einige
aktivisten vom schlachthof users und
umfeld sein werden also das werden dann
auch in der fraktion der grünen
spannende macht verteilungskämpfe also
mal ganz erreichen darf an der schienen
beiden ja schauen sie sich mal die
listen der grünen an da sind sehr häufig
kandidatinnen kandidatin der grünen
jugend relativ weit oben platziert die
haben aber nicht also keine begeisterung
dafür und ich möchte sie alle daran
erinnern dass beim letzten trio live
shows und annalena baerbock beide
unisono gesagt haben die union sollten
die opposition sollte sich dort
regenerieren
ich finde die analyse interessant aber
sie an frau blogger aber hat es heute
nicht so klar gesagt das stimmt das
erinnert hat er der punkt ist aber doch
unter einer spd geführten regierung
könnte es doch trotzdem so sein dass man
sagt gut wir haben da beinfreiheit wir
bedienen unsere themen klima umwelt
landwirtschaft sodass sie als der
treibende teil dieser koalition
wahrgenommen so gut hat jetzt nicht
gereicht aber rückspiels in vier jahren
das wäre aus meiner sicht noch eine
andere überlegung und vor allem muss man
dann ja auch immer noch überlegen der
preis innerparteilich der wehr enorm
hoch und sind das nicht vergessen
trennung von amt und mandat haben ja
eine situation wo es dann ja auch neuer
parteivorsitzender scheinlich geben wird
weil faktisch müssten die beiden schon
am kabinettstisch und ob man so eine
starke führung hat die sohn konflikt
auch aushalten können das glaube ich
nicht und das muss aus grüna perspektive
natürlich mit bedenken aber verluste
haben sie in beiden optionen egal ob sie
fan michael machen bei den grünen gibt
zerreißprobe so das so ja aber
wahrscheinlich über jede beute aber es
ist eben alles wieder so ganz einfach
und deshalb werden meine frage an
welchen themen oder wird es dann wohl
oder was werden denn die schwierigsten
themen seien wir haben ja jetzt heute
über das klima bisschen gesprochen über
steuererhöhungen wurde gesprochen also
wo sehen sie herr kessler die größten
differenzen also zwischen grünen und fdp
wo denken sie da kommen die gar nicht
zusammen das kann dann und da gewürz
dann wirklich drauf ankommen da muss ich
ja wie beim mikado irgendeiner zuerst
bewegen
ja ich glaube wenn der weg und dessen
will man sich bewegt an die tröge der
macht führt dann bewegt man sich ganz
gerne und die strukturen schaffen den
leidenschaften zur macht sollte man auch
nicht unterschätzen
die die größten baustellen gibt es
natürlich auf der finanzpolitischen
seite ist wird auch deutlich mehr wird
bei der klimapolitik selbstverständlich
ein selbstverständlich einen kompromiss
finden bei der außenpolitik sowieso bei
der finanzpolitik will ich das wirklich
schwieriger vor wie will man jetzt
weitermachen mit dem spitzensteuersatz
zb man will ja eher mehr steuern haben
bei den grünen man ist stärker für einen
umverteilen den staat als natürlich ist
die fdp ist dass sich also ganz großer
voraus große auseinandersetzungen voraus
wird die schuldenbremse gelockert
verbergen freiburg will das jahr wird
also eine art sozusagen klima
sonderbereich innerhalb der
schuldenbremse wurde das nicht
angerechnet wird das gleiche gilt auch
für die für die vergemeinschaftung
sollte auch dort klima bestrebungen in
der gesamten eu sollen auch an sozusagen
am sonntag karenz zonen eröffnet werden
wie es gerade politischer art das wären
also wirklich zu zerreißen führende
prozesse aber die wären schon
überbrückbar man würde formelkompromisse
finden und letzten endes wer ist dann
alles in allem glaube ich fast sogar
noch leichter zwischen der fdp und den
grünen als zwischen der fdp und den
linken ich darf daran erinnern dass
beispielsweise
natürlich und grünen und linken
sich zurück schneiden wir auskenne man
sieht hier wird nichts doch nicht nett
ich dachte das wäre
wäre ich so gar nicht gekommen
zu sein wir sehen ja beispielsweise dass
wir in baden württemberg ein richtig
unerfolgreich finanzminister von den
grünen haben der auch so als shooting
star gilt und man hat dort auch sich auf
eine einigermaßen solide finanzpolitik
geeinigt und das geht relativ
geräuschlos dauert zwischen cdu und
grünen unser denken sie wer an welchem
thema wird man am längsten vovo kommt
dann kommt die richtig langen
nachtsitzung wo wird richtig schwierig
wenn man allein tisch sitzt am personal
und ich glaube dass wenn die union die
grünen ködern würde mit wir haben ja
dann nächstes jahr noch eine
bundespräsidentenwahl es könnte erstmals
in deutschland eine frau eine grüne
politikerin bundespräsidenten eckart
wieja
zu leicht und den namen genau der ist
ich habe jetzt natürlich auch claudia
roth gelegen aber
göring eckardt ist diejenige die da am
häufigsten genannt wird wenn man sagen
würde die erste frau im außenamt die
erste deutsche außenpolitikerin könnte
die grünen hatten wir auch noch nicht
dann sag ich mal kleinerer teil
tempolimit 130 und flure kohleausstieg
dann wird das und so weiter und so fort
dann wird es für die für die
grünen-basis weil sie es vorhin
angesprochen haben gar nicht so einfach
sowas wegzuwischen und das muss
natürlich inhaltlich im klimaschutz
etwas passieren da kann diese
unbeweglichkeit die herr laschet beim
klimaschutz zeigen auch häufig die
unwissenheit er kann es nicht
durchdeklinieren er ist es auch im
wahlprogramm
wirklich so ein bisschen unter ferner
liefen läuft das klima ab da
müssen sie auf jeden fall so zu sagen
was daran geben und auf diesen auf so
ein paket würde es ankommen ob die
grünen dann nicht ob es das gesamtpaket
für die grünen bei jamaika dann nicht
viel
attraktiver ist herr söder hat heute
noch mal sand ins getriebe gestreut der
laschet hatte während des wahlkampfs
gesagt im wahlprogramm stunde keine
einzige steuerentlastung bei der union
das ist falsch da stehen eine ganze
menge steuerentlastung drin allerdings
unter dem vorbehalt
des wirtschaftswachstums und herr söder
hat heute mal nebenbei eben fallen
lassen wir sind für steuerentlastungen
das heißt also er hat da noch mal die
latte etwas höher gelegt und da deswegen
kommen teile ich das in der
finanzpolitik würde ist am schwierigsten
aber wenn nicht jeder in jedem bereich
etwas haben möchte sondern wie sie es
können können du kriegst das und du
kriegst das dann glaube ich auch nicht
dass es um wahnsinnig lange dauern würde
bis man sich auf eine neue regierung
einigen keine neujahrsansprache von
angela maier
ja nicht was neues feld sortiert es war
heute mal wieder so dass olaf scholz
keine angriffe in richtung grün gemacht
hat annalena baerbock hingegen schon
angriffe auf stolzen weil natürlich
deutlich wurde das sind wählerinnen und
wähler von der spd zu den grünen
gegangen zwischenzeitlich bei dem 28
auch die wir sie jetzt zurück zu
bekommen um eben zulässt eine klima war
gleichzeitig ist ja so dass beide sagen
also am liebsten wir beide das hat olaf
scholz auch ganz explizit gesagt
annalena baerbock durch die blume und da
schon auch deutlich wurde dass sie
faktisch gesagt haben und die kriterien
müssen erfüllt sein es wegen sie
eigentlich die koalition mit der linken
ausschließen gleichzeitig für sie wäre
es ja schon attraktiver in die ampel zu
gehen und sagen gut dann macht er halt
digitalisierung der macht ja auch was
für die wirtschaft das problem ist und
das teil ist nicht mit dem personal die
frei der schuldenbremse denn man muss ja
der fdp ordentlich was anbieten damit
ihr auch wirklich gut wir gehen in der
koalition die nicht unsere
programmatische eigentlichkeit
entspricht und die eben nicht unser
politisches lager ist und lindner will
das finanzministerium und das wiederum
heißt er könnte den ganzen sind aber
auch ganz stark für investitionen ja
aber die frage ist ob er diesen
investitions begriff der grünen so
teilen würde und da sich tatsächlich die
großen tag von euch noch eines geben
weswegen ich auch denke dass sie
tatsächlich eine ampelkoalition
präferieren würden weil in dem moment wo
man eine partei aus dem bürgerlichen
lager hat hat man nicht die widerstände
die man sonst hätte aus der gesamten
gesellschaft das heißt man hätte ja die
liberalen in der mitverantwortung hätte
so deutlich weniger widerstände als wenn
es zb ein rot grünes oder ein rot rot
grünes bündnis wäre sofern die in der
außenpolitik überhaupt eine übereinkunft
finden aber dafür einfach über platten
die länder aus der feder der betrachtung
ist jetzt wir konzentrieren uns nur auf
die bundesregierung aber diese republik
ist so verfasst dass es zwei kammern
gibt und in den bundesländern hat die
grünen zum beispiel starke position weil
sie in vielen landesregierungen sind
eine führen sie an die linken haben wir
gar keinen großen stich außer einem
kleinen thüringen die cdu und die spd
sind auch eher stärker ich glaube dass
sowie der bundesrat jetzt
zusammengesetzt ist und wenn ich mir
angucke welche land das war in dem
nächsten und im übernächsten jahr
anstehen die frage steht kommt man in
eine konfrontative situation mit dem
bundesrat so wie es sich entwickelt oder
kommt man in eine wobei de kann man sich
irgendwie einigen können das wird eine
spannende frage sein ich erinnere an
lafontaine der damals bevor der schröder
kanzler wurde versucht hat den bundesrat
zum quälinstrument des bundestages und
des kanzlers kohl zu machen ja ich
könnte mir sogar vorstellen dass das tri
allen sondern in die zukunft da ist weil
dieser gedanke den sie hatten wenn
laschet geopfert wird und man sagt okay
wir selbst wir setzen dann doch
irgendwie selber ein und man sagt okay
alle anderen konstellation haben wir
probiert und es ging nicht diese anderen
dreier konstellation und man dann sagt
das ist eben nicht die groko und sondern
findet auch eine erneuerung statt und
wir brauchen gleichzeitig eine breite
parlamentarische mehrheit in kombination
mit dem was sie gesagt haben werden
darunter mehrheit im bundesrat gleich
mit also das ist nicht einsetzen wir
haben auch jetzt nicht den csu-chef den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
wie meinen sie das einzel als
vizekanzler so also möglicherweise ihnen
denn bürger zu inthronisieren zu sagen
okay wir hätten ihnen herr söder als
vizekanzler das macht er nicht macht er
nicht er
wie man möchte dann muss ja kein
bundestagsabgeordneter sei er ein star
wird vom bundestag gewählt wer selbst
kein abgas sein wir haben jetzt ganz
wenig über herrn scholz gesprochen heute
wir haben viele bälle und hat und
lehrpersonal und herr lindner gesprochen
aber ganz wenig über herrn scholz der im
moment ja noch die umfrage anführt und
halt eben auch alle umfragen wenn es um
die kompetenz geht und wenn es um die
direkte wenn man direkt wählen könnte
dann hat er scholz die besten werte
jetzt wurde heute dann immer von der von
den anderen parteien gesagt ja aber dann
ist daher kühner dann ist der frau esken
also wenn ich ein scholz wähle frau uns
wie sehr bestimmen dann herr kühnert und
es kommen die politik mit der jüngeren
frau essen wird
die werden sich einen raum erarbeiten
und die halten natürlich jetzt still bis
bis zur wahl und bis zu bis zu den
koalitionsverhandlungen und dann wird
herr scholz sehr viel schwerer haben als
während des wahlkampfes
sie also gerade preston ist jemand die
mehr verantwortung übernehmen wollte
oder die auf jeden fall auch
parteichefin als parteichefin sich
inhaltlich da einbringen würde ich
glaube dass er es schwer haben wird mit
seiner partei er wird zwar wahnsinnig
bejubelt werden er hat ja dann wenn es
soweit kommt im übrigen etwas ganz ganz
wichtiges geschafft die spd haben wir
doch alle am anfang des jahres eher
richtung einstellig gesehen als dass sie
ein besseres ergebnis im vergleich zu
2017 erzeugen wird das heißt er wird
diese partei wenn auch wenn sie auch
schaden genommen hat an dem charakter
der volkspartei wird sie aber hat sie
wiederbelebt er hat sie gerettet egal
wie das jetzt ausgeht er hat diese
partei sei auch nicht der stellv er hat
die johannes als martin schulz ja genau
das ist genau umgekehrt martin schulz
ist hoch gestartet und ist dann sehr
tief gefallen und herr scholz war bis
juli bis auf fast august
zementiert in 15 prozent und dann ging
das nach oben das heißt das wird man ihm
sehr sehr sehr zugute halten und da wird
er
freiraum haben nichtsdestotrotz ist auch
diese partei breit aufgestellt und wird
ihn
vieles wird ihnen nicht die beinfreiheit
geben die er sich wünscht also wird herr
kühnert und von frauke werden die beiden
minister muss sie muss hier einbinden ob
ich weiß gar nicht ob herr kühn hat
unbedingt minister werden will ehrlich
gesagt er ich glaube der der sieht sich
gerne auch so ein bisschen in der
position dagegen bei fresken glaube ich
sie will ist gerne ob er muss natürlich
klar er muss mit diesen verschiedenen
strömungen in der
in der spd dann zurecht kommen und sie
einbinden er hat ja behauptet dass er
nicht
kanzleramt und parteivorsitz in einer
hand nehmen wollte dass das ein
bewährtes modell seite also damit gut
immer das ist ja das ist ein großer
fehler von gerhard schröder gewesen dass
er als kanzler den parteivorsitz
abgegeben hat und wir sehen das im laufe
der zeit auch wie es dann in der cdu
passiert ist das ist ein wagnis und dem
müsste sich herr scholz auf jeden fall
stellen wer herr kessler was denken sie
was kriegt man wenn man die spd wählt
wie viel wie viel das von der anderen
seite bekommt man
das wird es wird auf jeden fall eine
pralinenschachtel mit sehr vielen
verschiedenen sorten drin und manche
werden auch süß sauer und manche werden
auch bitter schmecken schulz sagt ja
immer heute ist dann kann man ja sagen
dann ist für jeden geschmack was dabei
dann bedient man ganz viele das ist doch
dann auch gut
dass das ist die frage manchmal kauft
man sich ja dinge die man vorher wissen
will was man kriegt überraschen können
ja auch zu enttäuschungen führen wenn
man solche ich weiß nicht diät macht
oder mandel nicht verträgt also erlassen
herr schulz sagt er immer bei
veranstaltungen heute aber nicht während
mich wählt er weiß was er kriegt ja man
weiß einigermaßen dass man herrn scholz
bekommt man weiß aber von dem umfeld
nicht immer weiß vom habitus hier ist
aber heute wieder auch gesehen ich habe
am anfang gesagt meister
perfektionierten blässe er weiß was er
sagen muss um nichts zu sagen wir haben
jetzt gerade diese schöne dokumentation
gesehen von herrn llambi wo er dann auf
fünf minuten einfach nicht bereit ist
die frage zu beantworten ob er das video
dieses negative campaigning video gegen
entlastet und sein umfeld gesehen hat
oder es abgesegnet hat oder nicht da
kommt dann ausufernde referat über
wahlkampfstrategien über einbindungen
von niederen parteigliederungen über das
was er gesehen haben könnte was aber
vielleicht nicht gesehen hat mag es
kommt kein ja oder nein dh wenn wir
herrn scholz während nach wie vor die
poleposition immer wenn wir hatten
scholz willkommen herr scholz bekommen
wir zunächst einmal einen habitus wir
bekommen ein habitus mit nachgelagerter
programmatik und der habitus ist es muss
sich eigentlich gar nicht so viel ändern
ich bin merkel ihm gut er hat heute ja
gesagt ein besseres leben ohne
einschränkungen ist möglich das ist die
scholz versprechen das leben ohne
einschränkungen und ob das möglich ist
ist die frage ja man darf nicht
vergessen dass linke parteien immer dazu
neigen programmierer zu sein und rechte
parteien mehr so nach
führungspersönlichkeiten ausschau halten
das heißt dass der wert eines
wahlprogrammes wird bei den linken bei
der spd und auch bei den grünen höher
eingeschätzt innerhalb der partei als
das bei den anderen parteien ist meiner
meinung nach und vor diesem hintergrund
muss man schon ernst nehmen was in den
wahlprogrammen dieser partei steht da
können sie spitzenkandidaten nicht
wirklich von frei machen aber er rechnet
also die unterscheidung die sie gerade
gemacht haben ist ja genau das
unterscheidet zwischen regierungs und
programm parteien aber wir haben ja beim
letzten mal erlebt dass tatsächlich die
fdp diese erwartung er eine
regierungspartei zu sein ja nicht
entsprochen hat das hat ja also an der
stelle enorm geschadet ich glaube diese
frage können sie sich auch nicht einmal
erlauben auf gar keinen fall also da
müssen jetzt wirklich in die
verantwortung ansonsten hat sie wirklich
ein massives problem ich glaube die
frage ist gar nicht so spannend ob und
welche rolle jetzt kevin kühnert und
saskia esken spielen die spannende frage
ist tatsächlich er in wie viel kann olaf
scholz auch von der programmatik umsätze
ich teile das dass das ein hartes und
versprechen ist und würde aber ein dass
noch hinzufügen es ist nicht einfach nur
ein erfolg in den wahlen sondern er hat
der sozialdemokratie eine erzählung
gegeben diese erzählung von respekt und
anerkennung die er ist jetzt wirklich
neue die auch wirklich auf vielen auf
der erfahrung vieler leute an fuß und
die auch tatsächlich in unsere zeit
demokratisches negativ passt das heißt
er hat nicht einfach nur dafür gesorgt
dass die umfragen hoch gehen sondern ihr
tatsächlich auch wieder eine andere
identität gegeben und hat dadurch sie
auch wieder wählbar gemacht für leute
die eben tatsächlich voll von der spd
weg waren aber ich teile des verbundes
was sie gesagt haben trotz dieses
erfolges wird er ordentlich ordentlich
eingelegt werden und keine beinfreiheit
haben denn wir sind ja immer noch vor
dem paradox er war nicht gut genug als
spd-vorsitzender arbeite auch selber
kanzlerkandidat will doch das ist so
eine art mitgliederbefragung gibt über
die koalitionsoption es heute sind ja
bekannt gegeben also dass das heißt da
da da muss er sich dem stellen freut uns
aber das ist jedoch schwierig ja und wie
die spd hat ja ein jahr lang wirklich
ruhe gehalten sie hat ja eine intensive
analyse gemacht warum sie sich über
jahre immer zerlegt hat weil sie ihre
parteivorsitzenden geschreddert hat und
das hat sie wirklich gut hingekriegt
dass sie jetzt ein jahr still gehalten
hat aber nichtsdestotrotz wird es ja
über dann die so etwas sollte es dazu
kommen dass sie also wirklich wieder das
land führen kann da wird werden meiner
ansicht nach mechanismen durchbrechen
dass man das soweit man das kann einer
basisdemokratie zu führt in der partei
und das da das auf breitere schultern
gestellt wird also da wird herr scholz
glaube ich
wird es noch mal so einen rück eine
erinnerung oder ich will nicht sagen ein
rückfall
grundsätzlich wenn man wenn man sie war
nicht das euere dass man es auch anders
kann genau also 1 bei allen dingen die
wir heute abend nicht wissen und erst am
sonntagabend wissen wissen wir auf jeden
fall dass angela merkel nicht die
nächste kanzlerin dann wohl wird und
herr scholz wurde ja kritisiert weil er
sozusagen die raute gemacht hat in
diesem foto wer ist denn aber herr
kirchner vom ganzen habitus von allem
eigentlich von hamburg laschet und
scholz am ehesten der typische oder die
typische merkel nachfolgerin
scholz und zwar einfach aus dem grund
dass er das interessanterweise hinkriegt
ja wirklich zu verkörpern einerseits
diese erfahrung so man kann mir
vertrauen aber so ein moderates
stabilität oder so murat moderators
veränderungs versprechen bringt weswegen
er auch eigentlich nicht mit der union
so stark an also müsste ja schon mit den
grünen regieren um dieses
modernisierungs versprechen einzulösen
und armin laschet hat eben genau das
nicht vermocht als er wollte über diesen
wohlfühl wahlkampf ins kanzleramt
einziehen das hat nicht funktioniert
weil da viele ereignisse dazwischen
gekommen sind und bei annalena baerbock
ist so dass sie durchaus sehr
angriffslustig ist dass sie sehr
pointiert ist dass die jungen menschen
sehr stark erreicht aber dieser wandel
dieser aufbruch das natürlich auch für
einige leute überfordert ist das heißt
stabilität setzen beide haben nicht mehr
so viel genauer frau habe da was denken
sie wer ist denn da der richtige bei
frau merkel hat ja immer noch hohe
beliebtheitswerte ja und da haben ja
beide versucht sowohl lastet als auch
scholz ihre art von kopie zu entwickeln
und ich glaube auch dass der herr
laschet dass sich zu leicht gemacht hat
oder ihnen das auch so beraten worden
ist das weiß man ja noch nicht und dass
herr scholz dann eleganten mittelweg
gefunden hat frau berg möchte ich sagen
die andere schluss ist interessant das
reizt auch leute auf aber die frage die
viele leute stellen noch in gesprächen
ist immer und wenn es danach an die
umsetzung geht da muss man ja moderieren
leute einbinden
da muss man auch viel zurückstecken auch
von der eigenen persönlichkeit und kann
sie das also das wird bei lassen und
scholz nicht gefragt das ist unterschied
dar ist und bei scholz sagt man oft
langweilig aber das ist da laschet auch
also da wird man ja
ja die deutschen mögen ihre den wandel
dann besonders wenn er sich selbst nicht
betrifft sprechen eines wandels ohne
sich zu bewegen das hat natürlich herr
scholz und laschet hat das große
kollektive problem dass er sich von der
merkel absitzen müsste um statur zu
gewinnen was eben weil er eben
parteivorsitzender ist nicht gelegen
hätten habe man als auch da die traute
gefehlt er hätte glaube ich den
ähnlichkeit wettbewerb gelassen den
konkurrenten scholz überlassen soll und
auf diesen einbindung und deshalb
mitverantwortung im kabinett verweisen
könnten er lacht nicht angehört und
hätte sich sagte aber doch immer wieder
an entscheidenden punkten von frau
merkel absetzen müssen um selbst statur
zu gewinnen und jetzt hat er sich selbst
ein comic kommunikatives dilemma gegeben
dass er sich nicht entscheiden kann er
sagt einerseits war es sehr sehr gut
aber trotzdem muss ich sehr sehr viel
ändern nimmt man eben nicht okay dass
man ihn nicht ab front und ist schon
besser ich würde sagen merkel ist nicht
kopierbar
[Gelächter]
sie ist was sie sehr unterscheidet von
allen ist ihre naturwissenschaftliche
herangehensweise an strategien an
probleme und da würde ich sagen tickte
sie immer etwas anders als die
kandidatinnen und kandidaten die wir
jetzt haben also dieser erzählung glaub
ich nicht da muss ich noch einen kleinen
wiederholt an wetten dass ist was ist es
selbst negativ von ihr immer dass
naturwissenschaft naturwissenschaftlich
also wenn man sagt vom ende her denken
dann müsste es von 20 1 waren sich ja
denkt man heute sieht vieles schlecht
aus
der vorgesehen wir sind am ende der
sendung wir haben jetzt so eine stunde
darüber gesprochen und wir wissen immer
noch nicht mehr kanzler wird frage ist
wann werden wir das wissen unsere lange
koalitionsverhandlungen das war meine
ursprüngliche voraus dass frau merkel
noch die neujahrsansprache das teile ich
explizit okay wir schauen vielen dank
herr kessler schüttelt den kopf wir
haben auch herr kessler der kirchen und
frau dunst und vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und natürlich ist phoenix rund
um die wahl die ganze zeit für sie da am
wahlabend natürlich auch und auch die
wahlkundgebungen also bleiben sie
einfach bei phoenix dann sind sie rundum
gut informiert schönen abend tschüss
[Musik]
das ganze geld
mehr als ein clay
linear und digital zeigen wir die welt
wie sie ist täglich rund um die uhr zum
schluss können sie sich eine meinung